[Music]
let's talk about that cuomo [ __ ] all i
got to say is cases are going up in new
york city
i love that that was a great tweet but
low-key
those some lion-ass [ __ ] bro you
think so lion ass [ __ ]
it's convenient timing in it no i just i
don't trust
it's convenient ass timing that the
second the second
cuomo stock starts to drop get these
aides whose career is tied to cuomo's
success whose political careers tied to
success are like
oh i gotta get out of this [ __ ] before
it sinks that guy said dirty words to me
i would i would agree with you if he can
touch somebody right no but he wore he
wears nipple rings i don't trust
anyone who wears sniffer chimp he's a
chimp
yeah but and he's a sexual deviant sure
right maybe but that doesn't mean he's a
[ __ ] rapist probably
maybe he says don't know the facts yo
maybe he said some crazy [ __ ] to them
what i don't understand is why didn't we
hear about this earlier why is this just
popping up now that's always it always
like when he was captain corona and he
was about to be the next president all
those aides were like
i'll deal with some flirty talk because
i'm going to get a position but don't
get a position in the government and the
second that [ __ ] getting
feasted on by the media vultures
immediately what happens immediately
right
oh yeah he said some inappropriate [ __ ]
to me i need to get out the devil's
advocate please go
maybe when he's everybody's beloved
what the [ __ ] is he governor yeah i
don't know governor
ruin the greatest city in the west yeah
yeah ruin the greatest city sucks but
maybe at that time when everybody's
praising him
you're like man everybody loves this guy
nobody's gonna believe me i can't
[ __ ] go at this guy
and then when you see him be vulnerable
you're like oh now people might
understand this guy
but usually he's a phony piece of [ __ ]
yo check it out i mean i i just see
shots on a tightrope walk around like
that
am i going to relate to the average
american so i'm a gang member
i knew he was in a mood when he started
with i thought r b standing for renting
blacks
i mean you owned there was paperwork
this wasn't a good job this was not an
airbnb
this was mortgage refinancing
i feel real real like conflicted about
slavery because it's so wrong
but it's also such good deals what do
you mean like as
if you're like a woke indian you'd be
like yo this is foul what they're doing
to these black people
but also what a bargain something we
don't know the prices bro
yeah i can't i can't imagine they were
getting fair value
i mean no it wasn't fair
can i make a point right now okay here
we go
do you think you would have been able to
get a netflix show
if your views were like 80 000 saying
what we just said
or like do you think it's even possible
or do you think
you know what i'm saying like you've got
to be in the millions to be able to
i got jokers like this i got offered
netflix when our numbers are less
yeah but i but i said no to it but that
was because my stand-up numbers were
crazy
right so the podcast was different right
yeah but yeah you guys need to build up
to get
also to do what we did on netflix you
need to be right
you need to be to do it your way exactly
because we just did it completely our
way
right right and shout outs to them for
supporting that and if you look at all
the history of the shows that have
worked hold on we were having a lot of
fun talking about
slavery what was it yeah good deals
oh yeah we don't even know the deal i
had this thought
let's go
alex loved the change in topic no no no
no let's go back no this is something i
really thought about
i'll be mistreating black people yo
there was a black kid at the show
yesterday i wouldn't even talk to you i
didn't even offer him a pepsi
oh it's a small picture coca-cola he
said do you want a coca-cola to the guy
and i was like i knew you were a fraud
bro
he was a southern black